time now for morning rounds with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
Narula
first up the power of exercise we know
how important it is to our general
health and that's also true when it
comes to pregnancy and an editorial
published this week in the Journal of
the American Medical Association focus
on the importance of exercise for most
pregnant women using the American
College of Obstetricians and
Gynecologists 2015 guidelines the
article highlights a recommendation for
20 to 30 minutes of exercise most days
of the week at a moderate intensity
combining aerobic and strength training
Tero have there been any studies about
how US women are doing it and just how
important is exercise for pregnant women
certain people would like to know so
there was a small study that came out in
2016 that looked at about 250 pregnant
women and asked them about their
physical activity and 60 percent of
those women reported no leisure time
physical activity and those meeting the
guidelines ranged anywhere from about 13
to 45 percent so not doing so great but
I love what the authors of the editorial
said which is really that pregnancy is
no longer considered a state of
confinement that exercise is not only
safe but it is beneficial it increases
your longevity your cardio respiratory
fitness your just overall emotional
well-being and it can decrease things
like gestational diabetes preeclampsia
problems in terms of increased risk of
of c-section so less risk of that in
addition less low back pain less pelvic
problems and less urinary incontinence
so all good things we're not talking
rock climbing here right what kind of
exercise are we first thing they do make
a specific point of saying is you have
to check with your doctor make sure it's
safe for you to do it but they're
talking about things like walking and
dancing stationary bike jogging swimming
the things that you should avoid are
things like very vigorous very ultra
vigorous stuff and high impact say
long-distance running or heavy weight
lifting but I love the fact that they
specifically point out a few other
things they said you should definitely
avoid boxing as you attempted ice hockey
and then my favorite is skydiving and
scuba divers they say
the first thing on my list if not things
not to do well my wife played golf the
day before she gave birth both times so
you know maybe it accelerates things a
little bit that's not on the list though
golf I don't think so it's quite good
but seriously are there are the people
who should who should not be doing this
kind of thing in their pregnancy so
there are certain groups of women who
it's recommended just stick to plain
walking and those are women with sort of
high-grade heart disease or lung disease
women who have severe anemia
pregnancy-induced hypertension or
preeclampsia those with problems meaning
that their increased increased risk of
ruptured membranes they have an
incompetent cervix bleeding in the
second or third trimester or placenta
previa okay okay
our next topic community health centers
a report from the Kaiser Family
Foundation found that these centers
provided care for more than 24 million
patients in 2015 including nearly one in
six individuals on Medicaid how do these
centers might be impacted by any new
health care law is a looming question
dr. LaPook took a closer look
despina every day at the Erie Family
Health Center in Chicago doctor mark
Simon sees patients mostly the working
poor people can come in and get their
cancer screenings their blood pressure
check the cholesterol checked and and
also I think equally important they can
they can have a medical home dr. Simon
has seen his practice dramatically
expand under Obamacare the number of
patients earing now serves has almost
doubled over four years - more than
68,000 63% get medicaid of the 24
million people the Congressional Budget
Office said could have lost their health
insurance under the most recent GOP
proposal Erie Health estimates that
could have included 9,000 of its
patients 61 year old retired taxi driver
Leslie Durham has heart disease and he
could be one of them what kind of
medical care were you getting before you
had the insurance no whatsoever
all I had to do is anytime I feel some
pain
I had to go to Cook County Hospital to
the emergency room I had to wake up at 3
o'clock in the morning to be there early
you want to be the first person and I'll
be the first person in line to get
inside to go to the ER Doron now
volunteers coaching soccer he's
recovered from quadruple bypass surgery
last year and dreads any change that
could leave him without insurance yet
again anything happen I'm gonna die not
only me me me others is this keeping you
up at night yes yes it is I see faces
and see smiles and I feel it that they
might be slipping away you know there
was another man that I meant another
patient when I was in Chicago 60
year-old man born in Greece
salt-of-the-earth worked hard his whole
life he fell on hard times
lost his private insurance had to go on
Medicaid he hated being on Medicaid even
though he had it he didn't go to the
doctor because he felt there was a
stigma attached to it and he told me and
he said I've goose bumps telling you
this because I've been so ashamed I
haven't even told my own kids he said I
was so ashamed to go to a Medicaid
person place and show my a Medicaid card
but now with Obamacare he was able to go
in and show just an insurance card and
he said nobody knew that he was on
Medicaid and nobody thought oh he's
looking for a handout he's poor it's
something I have to confess I really
haven't thought a lot about just yeah
when we have this debate over Medicaid
and health insurance it's important to
remember that there are human beings on
the front line of these stories